so
the the album like obviously when you
have a bodywork that's done you present
it to shady records right
you pick the song you want eminem on or
does he pick it well i did that i did i
don't know how i go usually but like i
was like
because when i played it
well i played it before i told him so
then when i played it he was like damn i
just hooked this hook is dope as [ __ ]
i was like [ __ ] well great it's the one
that's the one i wanted y'all that's the
one i wanted you on yeah man so like nah
i kind of we are we kind of catered you
know sound like we kind of catered that
[ __ ] like to like all right man let's if
we was going to get him on the song what
would you know i'm saying what i wanted
to be what do i want this [ __ ] to sound
like so like that's kind of like
why i kind of feel like it was easy for
him to just like walk straight into it
and it's gotta be hard too cause like
especially you brought up roy's m you
know i always say royce and i mean royce
is a [ __ ] jedi he's a maniac one of
the greatest of all time
but
you would think
you wouldn't like
you get your m verse back you get your
voice verse back you already got your
[ __ ] done
right yeah so you gotta like it's almost
like
you gotta had already had recorded that
hoping that they was gonna get on and
you went super stupid hard yeah or did
you like recut any of your [ __ ] i don't
recut man i don't recut man i i respect
the you know i i respect the [ __ ]
because you know sometimes it's cold
you'll send the record out with the hook
and then the open verse
see what see what's okay all right this
was good i know i don't know what i need
to do it's a code for me so like if i
most of the time i saw that saying if an
artist is bigger than you mm-hmm they're
gonna they're gonna want to hear your
[ __ ] on their face right because they
don't want to look crazy with the cool j
cannabis [ __ ] happening yeah so so you
know out of respect and just like you
know like i said it's a cold man like
all right cool i'm gonna send it with my
[ __ ] on there i'm gonna try to go as
hard as possible but some [ __ ]
gonna flip some [ __ ] to go crazy you
know what i'm saying like it's just like
hey it is what it is so like we're uh
with with them like with royce with
royce i had already had the song
constructed like the first half in the
second half so he just took the whole
middle you know i'm saying the whole
middle portion um and killed the [ __ ]
like which is what i was expecting him
to do anyways but then when i am [ __ ] i
spit at 16.
i was just trying to write some the most
[ __ ] right internal just did
that did that
lyrical score
like i was going in you know at the same
time trying to like do my own thing so
uh when i send it to him
you know
and he sent back and i was like i was
already knowing that he was coming with
at least 36 bars you know what i'm
saying like i already knew i was like i
bet like
he went in he just went the [ __ ] off and
it's like you know i i don't change [ __ ]
you know so i never i don't change
nothing like any time